bravery is having fear but you do it
anyway welcome back to new rock stars
this is the boys underground the show
that we talk about the boys and how
depressing it is and boy did i cry in
this episode
um i just i i only cried at black noir's
part you guys tell me if it's oh my god
tell me if it's okay that i cried at
black noise but i don't know if it is
almost like it is and then when oh you
went and sat in the corner oh you turned
the chair around i said someone stop him
he went like this so talk to him
literally we saw what happened in juan
division if you don't check in on your
teammates they raise hell and this is
what's gonna be happening to black noir
i'm here today with marina maestro
this episode of the boys episode 7 had
us so ecstatic at one point had me the
happiest i've ever been in this series
and then immediately knock me down
immediately punch me in the stomach and
i i will explain why but first let's
give it to marina do recap yeah
let's do it all right so vaude is on
damage control after starlet exposed
homelander for being an asshat and they
try to defame her accusing her of
running a child smuggling ring working
with chemical which is parallel to real
life like pizza rat and stuff like that
while homelander is spiraling uh
victoria newman approaches him with an
offer he can't refuse which by the way
the milk scene i was like i thought we
let this go they've ruined two of my
favorite songs in one episode you guys
ario speedwagons i can't take this
anymore was the song since i was a child
was like this is gonna be my first dance
on my wedding this is gonna be my first
dance on my wedding now the milk song
now no it's it was the most like it's
the old ladies it was the old ladies
soulja boy god okay this is not good
anymore and my mom god bless her would
be like i know exactly where this song
comes from for her and i was like no
that's not the reason don't say it oh my
god okay so uh
victoria newman catches him in the barn
and he still tries to cover it up which
i was like nobody
believes you uh so she offers him
something he can't refuse which is an
address to find ryan right so
he that's like his one weakness i would
say
french and chemical reunite with mm and
starlight to try and figure out what the
russians used to overpower soldier boy
with kimiko asked starlet to get her
permanent compound v to get her powers
back uh while looking for compound v
starlight comes across lab notes
detailing that after three to five doses
temp compound v becomes fatal
she also comes face to face with
hormlander which i was like thank you
she's not just going to walk in yes
thank you thank you i said especially if
she used her badge it's alerting
security and there's
okay i was like okay that's i believe
yes
but starlight airs out all of their
dirty laundry because she secretly had
her instagram on live to all her
followers and then he does a very bad
job of being like just kidding
we were running lines
and what world
[Applause]
oh my yeah
so then huey butcher and soldier boy are
now going after mindstorm who i always
every single time i'm like is it mind
hunter because of the netflix series oh
that's always like he's mind-hunting i
want to say i want to call a mind trap
all the time and i don't that's better
in mind
but so they're going after mindstorm who
can trap you in an endless nightmare
until you die of terminal dehydration
which i think is very funny
but mindstorm catches and puts butcher
into his own endless nightmare and this
is where we get to see butcher and his
younger brother lenny's traumatic
abusive past with their father and as
butcher goes through his past memories
he realizes that he's bringing down huey
with him leading him to death so on the
outside hughie and soldier boy track
down mindstorm and huey teleports
mindstorm to butcher's body to free him
from his endless nightmare and they're
always naked which is very amazing
then soldier boy comes out of nowhere
and immediately kills mindstorm but
before he dies he says his final words
to soldier boy which completely turn
everything upside down and it's later
revealed that soldier boy is home
lander's father
meanwhile i was right maeve is sitting
in a box
she's sitting
uh and she is super captive in vaught
tower kept alive solely to harvest her
eggs which is super gross to make
homelander a stronger offspring the deep
is having questionable threes oh my god
yes he is again and uh his wife said oh
my god you guys look at this
look at this puppy look at this baby
he's so sweet
hank is this you dare not cut yeah do
not cut this do not cut this we need to
know how fun we have are you a baby are
you a baby are you a baby are you a baby
are you a homelander's offspring are you
all like just asking oh he's trying to
play oh my god all right so adrian is
awake and now has blue hawks heart which
is gotta
really mess him up a little bit
and with a lot of therapy he can run
again so our favorite baby boy black
noir
who we found out is brain damaged from
uh soldier boy
so sad is definitely struggling to
confront his past on payback we get some
gruesome flashbacks played by animated
animals which was so fun i loved it
i really did i was like this is the best
and we find out just how terrible
soldier boy was to the team especially
black noir black no he just hated him
but also that i guess it kind of follows
the comic line that he was like a clone
of homelander it's like he was supposed
to be also just as good as homelander so
why wouldn't he be just as good as
soldier boy uh so soldier boy is like
this is a threat yeah this is a threat
and he sucks i should be doing all the
things probably that's fine you guys i
can't tell you enough how i cried but
first let me get into our ads be sure to
check out our awesome merch options over
at newrockstarsmerch.com we're currently
featuring our lace obsession shirt the
miss marvel inspired shirt titled cosmic
daydream uh this shirt is limited
edition and won't be available for long
it's only during the time of miss marvel
so you make sure you go and get it over
at new rockstarsmerch.com also just
because it's coming out today after this
shoot i'm flying out to rtx austin uh
we're gonna be doing a panel tomorrow
morning um at the hilton make sure to
come see me tommy phillip molina and
eric voss do a lot of fun bits and give
out prizes and hang out with you along
with seeing just everybody else in
austin at rtx fiona nova iffy noah
a lot of great folks uh make sure you
get your tickets i think single days are
sold out so you have to get the three
day pass now which is friday saturday
sunday get it and if you use new
rockstars all one word um as a promo
code you get discounted price and we
know you're coming
it's like an rsvp uh make sure to do it
don't skip out okay
now it's time for missable details yes
and i have a ton you guys i have a ton i
have a ton here i got a ton of hot ones
um
the episode title here comes a candle to
light you to bed is volume 10 episode 5
of the comics which again doesn't share
much similarities other than its working
title which comes from a nursery rhyme
called oranges and lemons loosely
theorize the deal with child sacrifice
and public executions but it's also a
children's game similar to red rover or
musical chairs so there'll always be
like
a pair at the end okay so kind of
mirroring this episode because
everyone's in pairs a i won't i'm i'm
mainly meaning like homelander and
soldier boy
um and
red rover is kind of what we're doing
right now
come on over in ashley's attempt to
smear starlight she brings up her
connection to kamiko saying she's part
of the shining light liberation army
this is the organization that kidnapped
kimiko and her brother and turned them
into soups in season two it was the
entire
overarching of season two basically uh
we see black noir doodling be a beaver
in episode four now we know he's
hallucinating buster beaver from buster
beaver pizza restaurant clearly a play
on chuck e cheese but buster beaver
pizza restaurant is also featured in a
commercial in some of the boys own
promotional pieces encouraging users to
go to
www.busterbeaverspizza.com which
ultimately redirects you to the boys
prime video page which is just a fun
little team yeah i did it for you so you
don't have to google it so you don't
have to google it and be like why is it
keeping me to the boys page like i did
uh they also mentioned black noise
incident at the hard rack cafe in
episode one season three with bob singer
talking to stan edgar he said this
should be brought up on war crimes
my baby my baby soldier or baby soldier
boy no baby black noir uh soulja boy
tells huey i'll slap you like connery
referring to how sean connery mentioned
in a 1965 playboy magazine interview i
don't think there is anything wrong in
hitting a woman soldier boy clearly has
outdated morals in speech comparing
mindstorm to pilot uh howard hughes
without the piss jars
it's honestly one of his best traits in
the series is how old he is
how he missed the last 40 years i love
that he's into older women by the way
aren't you aren't you don't you like
older ladies yes he does yes he does oh
they're lady man oh that's my boob
but i was i was like thank god he's into
older women weird line he said though he
was like but the dryer they i know it
was worth it though i was like good for
him for being into women
oh that is also true that is also true
these are technically women his age very
much his age uh and a horribly gruesome
flash pack we're gonna peep the allegory
that soulja boy is clearly the eagle
america's icon yeah crimson countess the
fox which in the 70s they referred to
much hot women as the fox black noir is
the black sheep because he is the black
sheep in his own family the payback he
is he is quiet unwanted but also the one
that follows all the rules this episode
is filled with symbolism um mirroring
also everyone that has a dad every
single thing in here is about fathers
and how fathers are bad
[Laughter]
shout out to mine uh we're introduced
we're introduced to mindstorm
who i'm pretty sure is mine droid in the
comics he has telepathy he's able to fly
with a jet pack but though he seems like
a robot he's a human in a robotic suit
kind of like vision still a member of
payback he also has a romantic
relationship with crimson countess uh
the scene where butcher beats the
principal with a stapler was inspired by
the moment in volume 10 issue one of the
comics when butcher struck a teacher at
school along with having his first beer
with his father while vaughn news is
interviewing lamar bishop the possible
vp pick underneath a red bar reads the
starlight drink adrenochrome adrena
chrome uh which i can't pronounce
because i don't do the drug you guys
i i do that too you're like i actively
doing it a psychedelic drug made in the
50s and 60s that johnny depp and benicio
del toro uh enjoying fear and loathing
in las vegas but is also
uh q anon's most obsessed patient i
guess this is amongst other things
clearly mirroring true events to appear
more realistic in the series how
homelander blames and attacks the media
the taco bulls in support of supersonic
the list goes on they're they're
mirroring something in reality and we
all see it
i think people forget about the
talkables
because when that happened they're like
oh yeah he did that and i'm like yeah he
did that yeah he did that how do we
forget i know
the cinco de mayo he did that yeah god
he's a horrible person okay to be more
specific
the temp compound v can leave you in a
vegetative state or death it looks like
according to the lab work additionally
it can leave you with hyper-accelerated
malignant tumors atrophy of the cortex
and some patients had seizures that
lasted one to two hours
that's not this isn't suppose this is
supposed to be helping people this ain't
helping anybody yeah uh we get the story
behind butcher's little brother lenny
whose death by suicide was actually a
story created by the show in volume 10
issue four
uh we learned that lenny was killed by a
random bus accident oh
yeah
in season three episode three they give
ryan's location to victoria newman which
i think is the address clearly that she
gives homelander in this episode in um
in episode three they also gave that
address or well they gave it to victoria
newman who they assumed they gave to um
edgar stan stan edgar edgar stan who
they gave to stan edgar so clearly more
than
five people know the whereabouts of
where ryan is it's happening next yes so
that is our missible details um and now
we get into our big questions
number one big question for me at least
yeah where does black noir go from here
our little baby oh my god i don't
okay so i know that he clear okay so
clearly like you said he has brain
damage from
what soulja boy did and so it leaves him
in like a child-like mind state these
are his best friends he it brings him
back to the place he felt safe right
i don't like that they are also like you
have to confront him i'm like you don't
there when they were like you knew he
was gonna come back it's like
i didn't and also yeah it's okay to
think he wasn't yeah i don't i don't
that was the whole point of giving them
away yeah there was a whole point of
giving away when you give something away
you don't want it back yeah so i i'm
sorry the puppy
i i just don't
it's
i don't want him to fight
i know he's been through enough he's
also murdered a million people but right
now
i need her
but so so he wants to be comforted he's
in the state of uh you know being
fearful in the corner he was sitting in
the chair
in the corner which i was so sad about
but so i think he goes to stan edgar
yeah
that makes sense that makes sense
actually he was the he was the one who
set up
the plan to give soldier boy to the
russians in the first place so if i were
black noir one stan edgar is a source of
comfort or at least he knows him really
well
and he knows him before his accident or
his accident before soldier but [__]
him up
but before all that so i think he's
going back to stan to be like you you
made me do this in the first place you
put me up to this and now the
consequences are coming back so i'm not
about to do this by myself i like that
because that's also a full circle we get
back to stan edgar it's not because my
uh my mom was like no he's dead
[Applause]
we talk every night after the show drops
we watched at five and she was like i
thought he was dead and i was like no
he's just gone he's like on permanent
leave yeah like i don't know how you
call it permanent when he's gonna come
back yeah um i actually thought that he
would team up with the boys they would
like if um if homelander and soulja boy
team up he's like
i need i need help but i think yours
makes more sense because if he does have
that childlike mind yeah um then maybe
he's like i need to go to the person
that put me in this position and see
what he wants me to do if he's been a
follower but i also could see this being
the moment that he finally is leading
it's like yeah no longer am i a follower
but then he gets his head smashed and i
don't want to see that again i don't
want to see it again but you know what
yours would create a lot of tension
because they he's killed a lot
they're friends and so it would be like
okay we're willing to work with you for
a purpose but but also you murdered
super a lot of people you murder that's
the thing is still butcher works with
soups knowing that he hates them i love
that conversation he had maeve in the
episode where they got to get it on
where he was like even you like i hate
you
i hate all of you but also i think
there's a reason why there was like
a little bit left of that permanent
compound v
so i'm like i think this is when they're
finally gonna change either those two or
the rest of the gang uh frenchie and mmm
they're gonna probably just jump in to
help they're going to change you think
they're going to make uh one of the the
gang permanent
someone's going to become permanent i
think with that leftover you know what
that's a good catch because i did i
looked at that when they was left over
and i was like damn i guess they just
like you just need a little more than
one dose and i was like he didn't even
measure how many cc's or whatever to be
fair
the lab
at vaught tower
is completely
backwards this is a rotating door it's
just a rotating door and they don't know
how to do their who leaves their notes
out
there's you're working with a million
people in there who leaves their notes
out you take it with you you keep it on
you and then on top of that i was just
like because we were even like how's
maeve just getting the
temp compound i guess if you have a soup
you can just walk in there and take it
out the fridge like it's a damn gatorade
i know it was it's also like very nice
that they are color coded yeah yeah
if they were different if they weren't
different colors she would have been
like oh
i gotta go read the notes that are all
over here on the board took a bunch of
them so stupid
second question is it even possible in
this world in the boys world right for
homelander and soldier boy to really
team up
right i mean because that's where it's
headed yes we hope or at least i would
like to see it for like five minutes
we're gonna get it they get good they i
think they can do it for
i'm gonna give like an actual prediction
of how long they can manage this is a
good day yeah because i think they will
and then it will fall apart obviously
but i think the bet is how long do they
manage to keep it together which is
i'm going to i'm going to oh no
i'm going to say literally because time
goes so
fast in this episode there was a scene
where i was like i love this episode and
i looked at the timer and it said 14
minutes so i think
i think it's going to be within a minute
30. a minute 30 they're going to
recognize there's going to be a speed
bump the homelander is going to start
being like this isn't going to work like
in a minute 30. okay okay okay okay so
so if it's under over then i mean i'm
going over but i'm going to say
not past
oh you know what i'm going to say 15
minutes 15. i'm going to say they make
it either at least to 15 minutes but
yours is honestly funnier i think it i
think he's gonna say something
he's going he already did he said you
think you're strong you wear a cape
that's his son he said it to his son so
it's like he already has this hostility
i love this overall this is fun
they're both okay so clearly let's go
through also why they can't work
together they're both alphas not long
term both outfits both alphas uh both
horribly uh
going along with being alphas
misogynistic they they cannot work on a
team with women also thirdly they will
figure out that they both had sex with
stormfront and
i don't think it's going to be a good
thing
oh
daschle he won't come on cam but he was
the one that made the note that maybe
possibly
a storm front is the mom yeah they used
stormfront eggs and they used uh soulja
boy's
sperm
and
homelander was a very it had an oedipus
thing happening
i don't disagree with him i don't
disagree with daschle i could see that
happening
and then he's gonna be throwing it into
a toilet for 20 minutes in an episode
he's going to be so disgusted when he
finds out but honestly it makes sense
yeah dude
this sounds like i'm screaming the gun
he also loves drinking that milk so it's
like
it's a one in one
it's one on one do you think um they'll
approach stan together now that it's
like you took away my son and then it's
like you took me away from my dad oh
that could be how every team meets is
through stamps yeah like that could be
black noir goes there the boys follow
the other
the homelander and them there and then
homelander in them are seeking them out
i think maybe you're right because but
then okay yeah you're right because now
they have a reason to because before
they didn't really have a reason to ever
but everything has been
being been leading back to
how did this come about they would never
do anything without bots permission
and so
you're right they would both be like you
took my kid away you took my dad away
so maybe they come to get him but black
noir has already
zooped him away well the thing is i'm
still wondering does victoria newman
still have that attachment to him
because she's like he's not dead he's
just he just lost his position and also
she said she was protecting him yeah
that is that is true so do you think
she'll pull up at the last minute and
it'll just be an all-out suit brawl i
mean i
hope so i she has to explode some more
heads she does have to explode uh stan i
could see her exploding some heads in
defensive trying to save him that was
one of my favorite lines from homelander
where he was like go ahead try to
explode my head because if it doesn't
work i'm going to kill you and i'm like
that's enough to make me not want to do
it that's enough to make me not want to
try yeah and honestly she might just
give him a headache
yeah he's like ow migraine fire
just
what is that robot game oh rock himself
yeah rock em sock em her head off uh
also
i feel like by the end a lot of soups
will lose their powers because of
homelander yeah i think if they all do
meet at sam edgar's he will explode and
the remaining superheroes that showed up
there will all lose their powers and
with that being said
i don't think black noir would survive
because he's so permanently his head got
split in half and he healed
so it's like when you don't have that
regenerative properties you're
constantly it's like your human form
could it have sustained all of those
injuries so i don't i think a lot of
them would end up dying or at least
black noir would yeah and
honestly probably for the best i feel
too bad for him and he killed a lot of
people right now but he did definitely
murder a lot of people blindly follow
people that he shouldn't have blindly
followed third question how is starlight
going to save huey she mentions that uh
she's going to save huey in what way is
it stopping him from doing drugs or
stopping him from working with soulja
boy
i mean the
to me was the v like stopping him from
getting or not getting but
using v still and also
if she destroys this is my
thought is like if she manages to just
like somehow destroy all temporary v or
just broadcast it to the public that it
exists and that it's bad for you
then that would essentially like make
them stop making it maybe and then she
could save him that way but
i think tal i hope he's not in a state
where telling him the truth is gonna
turn him away because i'm like all you
would have to tell me is three to five
doses is lethal and i would stop because
i'd be like i'm on third he's already
taken i think he's taken three but
butcher's taking like five because he
took it he took like two before huey
knew
it was a two yeah i think well the
second one was hughie knowing okay okay
so he was like give me that and he was
like no yeah but the first thing i'd be
like in the three to five range and i
was like how come you guys are not there
both of them are like one away from
dying and that is why
this is the i think this next episode is
the last episode
yeah it
all hands on deck for the last episode
you thought they were preparing us for
hirogasm yeah and then this episode
happened and then wait for episode eight
that one will be explosive that's gonna
then we gotta wait three years uh
but yeah i think also she should have
just destroyed all the compound view
when she was at the lab i know you
should have just got rid of it yeah
starlight started a electrical fire yeah
do something go geeky
do your eye thing to it um
yeah just stop him from doing the drugs
he's clearly uh turning into cheese
turn the swiss
cheese uh la a fifth question how can
maeve really get out
you're gonna chase me
so i thought about this because uh the
because i was like how are they gonna
harvest her eggs so i think when um
she could either say like oh no
something's wrong in the process of like
trying to harvest or whatever and be
like oh no oh and then whoever comes in
to get her i assume will be not a soup
and then she can
get her way out or like when they first
try to
come in and like i don't know sedate her
or do whatever she can hopefully just
get whoever it is that comes in unless
it's homeland and then i don't know what
she's gonna do so i would hope that
homelander and i when i say i'd hope i'm
just assuming uh homelanders not dumb
enough to make sure that it's just a
normal guard right like they have to
like
more than one yes and they would like
they have to sedate her so they have to
act there has to be a lot of them but um
yeah maybe she would they would be like
take this pill or whatever oh true well
it seems like she's not eating she's not
doing anything in that um in that box
but
do you think we're gonna even get her
out at the end of this season it seems
like they're preoccupied with so many
other things it seems like maeve's the
last thing on their list maybe she's
being saved for the next season maybe i
mean i hope although this is what i want
i want her to escape and at the last
minute come to help just like but that's
they did that last season comes to help
with um not now what does that what's
your name stormfront when she comes to
help with stormfront so i don't think
they're going to do it twice so i'm
going to be
it sucks because they haven't actually
given maeve that much of a
a hard storyline since like the first
season where we just found out that she
was bi uh so it's like since then she's
kind of been in the
the shadows but i'm still like this is
still a woman that
was abused and i want her to i want her
to pull through yeah i want her to pull
through so bad but it's like
what if she just loses her powers in the
process of fighting do you think he'll
still want her eggs
okay so this is a question yeah will you
still have the eggs that can make a soup
oh yeah because you because all of the
eggs are already in your body yes that
you have over your lifetime they're
already there so the eggs would still be
super
i mean maybe i feel like if you maybe uh
soldier boys blast does reach every part
of your organs so it gets rid of them
but there was um online people talking
about how um soulja boy is the first
uh not soldier or the first uh born
superhero to make an actual egg baby
but that is also false because we have
translucent that had a son and i think
another superhero also had his son so
if you can still have suns
with or without being given yeah
compound v at the start of your life or
just born with it um okay so we hope
maeve gets out but if you're listening
amazon
don't do mave like that i know also if
you kill black nomado let me see it put
it put a warning label up
um okay and lastly what awaits them in
russia we now know that uh kimiko kimiko
and frenchie are and mother's milk
have now they were they spent the entire
episode trying to find a way to knock
out soulja boy they realized that the um
the like not terrigen agent that's
marvel um the nerve the nerve agent the
russian nerve agent was not the one that
they gave him in hero gasps also
actually really funny
he picked it up
i said oh after that i was like oh guys
don't kill me um but they figured out it
wasn't the same it had a different
consistency it's something else that
they need to go back to russia to get so
first off little nina's on the loose
yeah do they think that's a smart idea i
know i i well obviously she's gonna be
she's involved with that whole thing
because in an episode prior she said our
lab oh she said our lab
so she's obviously part of the oh do you
think she went back to the lab i i mean
i don't see why she wouldn't but but
this is what i hope this is not like a
super plot point but like the answer to
the question that i want to be to have
which is like what awaits them in russia
is i wanted to be
more of the
russian superheroes that they got to
develop yes like the hamster
yes
trying to in trying to go to russia and
take the nerve agent
they just want to unleash 100
like the comic books like the comments
and the comic books they gave the temp
compound v vat gave her the temp
compound v which she gave to a bunch of
criminals in russia to stage a coop in
russia and then she exploded all their
heads i want that to happen
so bad and that could happen for the
next season we need to keep thinking
this season did so well how are they
gonna go off in the fourth season and
that is how they can go off on the
fourth season they get to russia and
they're like okay look for the nerve
agent and they see like a line kind of
like an um and uh it wasn't civil war
but it was in the marvels uh in the
marvel movies when they show up when
bucky shows up and sees the other
casings of where the other super
soldiers were oh yeah so i want him to
pull up and see the other super soldiers
in this and be like oh hell no and if
they're all hamsters or something
oh yeah make them different yeah make
them different and they can and there's
so many characters that they're missing
from the comics like i want to see
shaheem that's just like a she-hulk with
a hump on her back she could be in that
they have so many characters that they
could bring in and it would be so fun
topple homelander bringing all these
russian agents yeah
it was all new
are you listening jeff and now to our
kill count okay yeah pretty simple this
time so all the kills in this epilogue
all the kills in this episode belong to
soldier boy uh he shoots the priest and
the nun on the side of the road and he
bashes in the head of mind storm in the
woods and unbelievably that's it for the
whole episode so total episode kill
count is three and they all belong to
soldier boy that's insane all right i
also forgot about that nun scene
it was funny it was i was i literally
this entire episode was like you guys
shouldn't have gave him this weed he's
paranoid i was like he's paranoid as
hell and then as soon as it turned out
that he was right i don't know i was
like oh damn
oh god oh my god oh she's gone i'm dying
no the nut that nun scene i'm tired of
this exorcist [__]
that was so funny the lines in this
episode were so good that is it yeah for
the boys i'm done she's done she's done
until next week when we come with the
finale episode we break down what maybe
this can lead for the next season if
there is next season there better be i'm
talking to you amazon oh my god um this
episode was so great i feel like at the
beginning i i would start these shows
with
how much despair can we go through how
much can homelanders succeed and now
we're finally seeing it starting to
crumble even though it seems like it
isn't it is it is we're starting back
around
follow us on new rockstars everywhere
follow marina at marina mastros
everywhere yeah yeah follow me
follow me and lulu clemens uh you can
also follow me here in burbank uh follow
the rockstars on youtube and all social
media platforms make sure to hit that
notification bell make sure to check out
our tumblr make sure to check out us in
rtx austin and make sure to buy our
merch
have a nice day uh to be crazy is to
have fear what does he say bravery is
being fear oh god buster beaver
[Music]
[Applause]
you